[Music]
but you must be seeing on your screen is
a dot on the left and a plus sign on the
right with a yellow background color we
are going to perform a demonstration to
find the blind spot of our eye yes
our eye has a blind spot what is it
though and what does it mean it is a
spot on the retina of the eye where we
cannot see the light when its incident
on it I will explain its details a
little bit later but first I would prove
its existence to you through an
experiment ok let's go back to the start
again close your left eye and stay still
with your right eye focused on the dot
yes I want you to stay still and
concentrate with your right eye on the
dot present on the left of your screen
now with your left eye closed I want you
to slowly bring your face towards the
screen at some point in time you will
find that the plus sign on the right
disappears yes but in order for that to
happen you must focus only on the dot
and nothing else ok try it one more time
you can cover your left eye with your
left hand focus only on the dot and
slowly come closer to the screen did you
find the plus sign disappearing at some
point I'm sure you did you can try it
again left eye closed and focus on the
dot
you can do the same thing using a blank
piece of paper draw a dot on the left
and a plus sign on the right make sure
that there is nothing else written or
drawn on the paper hold the paper at
arm's length with one hand preferably
the right one close your left eye with
the other hand and focus your right eye
on the dot bring the paper towards you
again you will find that a thumb
distance away from you the plus sign
disappears at this distance it will seem
to you that there is no plus sign
present this distance is different for
different people and the other image
disappears only at a particular distance
if you
go closer you will see the blurred
version of the other image and yes even
if you close your right eye and focus on
the plus sign while coming closer you
will see that the dot will disappear so
next let's get into the details of this
and see how and why it happens so there
is a blind spot present in the eye we
have already discussed the structure of
the human eye in a previous video we
note that the convex lens present in the
eye focuses the light on the retina and
the retina has two types of nerve cells
cones and rods these cells transfer the
sensation to the brain through the
nerves these transporting nerves are
present in front of the nerve cells they
are connected directly to the brain and
hence they transfer the message to it
they go into the brain through this
region and this region is called the
blind spot the junction of the retina
and the optic nerve is called a blind
spot unlike the rest of the retina this
region does not contain nerve cells and
hence no signal is transferred to the
brain the reason that we are not able to
see the plus sign from the right eye at
some distance is because at this
distance the lens in the eye focuses the
light in this region and since there are
no nerve cells present in this region no
message reaches the brain and that's why
they say that every person is partially
blind it's because every eye has this
blind spot there is another interesting
thing about the human eye that you got
to know and that is any picture persists
in the eye for about 1/10 to one
fiftieth of a second that's right it
means that the brain retains the
impression of that light for
approximately one fifteenth of a second
after the source of that light is
removed that is very little time this is
referred to as the persistence of vision
and let me explain this in detail I have
many different images with me here's the
first one the second one the third one
and the fourth one and so on there are
many such different images now let me
take you back to the
first image let me show you successive
images slowly I will show you one image
per second yes this is how it will look
now let me show you successive images at
a rate of two images per second this is
how it looks now let me increase the
rate to five successive images per
second how does this look our eyes still
notice the changes and now I increase it
to 12 images per second it almost looks
as if it's a video right then I show you
24 images per second it looks like a
video this is because of the persistence
of vision the changes go unnoticed they
appear to be one continuous thing when
the images are flashed at a rate faster
than 15 per second the eye perceives the
object as moving the movies that we see
also use this property of her eyes
called the persistence of vision what we
see is the take but still images shown
to our eyes at a rate faster than 15
images per second
usually this rate is 24 images per
second however recent movies have gone
up to 48 images per second
imagine 48 images shown to your eyes in
just one second the eye is such an
important sense organ in humans so it is
necessary that we must take care of it
just like any other part of our body our
eyes can also get damaged in order to
prevent that from happening one must
take preventive measures we will discuss
few of those in our next video
[Music]